it is natural for most of us to spend
time worrying about our reputation what
others think of us whether we're deemed
good or bad by the community
this can quickly become a painful topic
and our thoughts can descend into
bonfires of worry what if we're accused
of something what if we're ostracized
and mocked what if we become a pariah
a useful way out of the panic was
suggested many centuries ago by the
stoic thinkers of ancient Greece and
Rome they suggested that we divide the
topic of reputation into two parts on
the one hand who we are and what we
think of ourselves and on the other what
other people may decide to declare or
say about us
stoics reminded us of an important
detail we can never be certain of the
second part of the equation we cannot
control the world Beyond a certain point
there is always the possibility that
someone vengeful mean or disturbed is
going to say something about us and try
to damage us we can never be completely
assured that they won't
this could sound like alarming news but
the stoics wished us to take it on board
with courage and then gain strength from
focusing on the first part of the
equation what we think of ourselves and
here things are far far brighter because
we're far more in control we can calmly
evaluate what we've done what our hearts
are like and we can then come to review
of what sort of people we are which can
provide us with a vital bulwark against
the possible vagaries and tempests of
public opinion we have a solid anchor we
can know who we are
modern Psychotherapy would add an
important detail to this analysis our
sense of who we feel we are is often
highly distorted in a negative Direction
by our past which can make us far more
jittery about public opinion than his
our sense of self is the result of how
other people viewed Us in childhood
especially our parents or caregivers
some of us wander the world with an
acute sense of Shame and self-distrust
that we absolutely don't deserve and we
project a lot of paranoia and fear onto
other people primarily because we have
been treated with disdain in our early
years we're going to start to feel a lot
more solid and immune from the ups and
downs of Gossip once we become conscious
of how negatively biased we've been and
settle in our minds what we think we are
worth irrespective of either what
figures from our past said or what
someone around us now might suddenly
decide
path to immunity from worry about
reputation is going to lie in a far more
secure and just handle on our own value
self-knowledge is a new essay book that
takes us on a journey into our deepest
most elusive selves and arms us with a
set of tools to understand our
characters properly